pourquoi avez vous choisi de poser les
bras croisés c'est un signe d'ailleurs
vous les avez là c'est ainsi une
d'autoprotection a priori ans dit ce
type est mal à l'aise il refuse le
contact avec les autres c'est ça qu'on
se dit quoi ah oui oui oui j'ai je vous
avoue que j'ai pas calculé comme ça je
sais tu es une série de photos que
j'avais fait le plus récemment ouais je
voulais pas reprendre parce que moi vous
savez je suis enfui
quand j'ai quelque chose j'aime le
conserver et quand je suis amoureux de
l'une des rares photos que j'aime de moi
donc je me dis bon c'est là mais je peut
la tenir vingt ans c'est un peu ridicule
donc là j'avais une série de photos
récentes et est donc on l'a prise mais
vraiment gpat attention aux bras croisés
les bras croisés j'ai en plus il sacré
toujours le même illusion d'optique vos
mains sont plus grosse de la marque et
bien voyez vous regardez vos mains elles
sont plus grosses que votre tête là sur
la photo
vous m'apprenez quelque chose et voilà
j'ai pas fait exprès
[Musique]